there are a few ways that you can build
up tension in a movie scene through
camera work through pacing and probably
most commonly through music like the
music you're hearing right now in this
incredibly tense scene from Steven
Spielberg's 2005 film Munich except
there is no music in the scene what I'm
getting ahead of myself let's back up we
all know that movies have only two ways
into your brain through your eyes and
through your ears but if you've ever had
the chance to edit a movie or a short
film or even a small video it quickly
becomes apparent that when you're
watching something these two senses are
weirdly interconnected the visual side
of film gets most of the attention
because it's right in front of you and
it's usually what you remember after a
movie is over but in many ways the
visuals are simply the face of the
operation while the audio is actually
the puppet master the one that really
holds the power okay let me show you
what I mean take a look at this scene
right here
[Applause]
so what does Spielberg want you to pay
attention to here
these people walking by and this car
passing no it's not what Spielberg once
it's what I want since that was the
sound design I just made for that shot
here's what the actual shot sounds like
[Music]
besides being infinitely better it's
easy to notice how the sound really
affects what you see and from what
perspective you see it in my version the
shot had an omniscient third person
point of view in the real version as
soon as the audio starts you're placed
in a perspective the first thing you
hear is a conversation from street level
so even though the long lens is fixed on
Eric Bana
you know the moment is taking place on
the ground then to drive the point home
you hear Daniel Craig singing the
temptations and the vocal recording is
close intimate even though you never go
inside the car that's enough to put you
there then the car that you're really
supposed to pay attention to the black
one parks and the sound of it parking
jumps out and mechs just like you
wouldn't hear Daniel Craig in that way
from where the camera is you wouldn't
hear the car that clearly but the sound
design picks these things out to tell a
specific story
still stays shut up the point here is
that in film you really do see with your
ears more than you think and sound
doesn't mind that image gets the credit
because a key to the power of sound
design is its invisibility
if dialogue sounds close then you are
close to the person who's speaking it
wherever they are my brothers would
choose my papon my sister were both
aimed okay so back to the sequence oh
yeah forgot no music this four minute
and 50 seconds scene is without music
and almost entirely wordless how does
Spielberg and legendary sound designer
ben burtt who gave the world this how do
they build the tension here well Burt
does it by building a bed of constant
noisy city ambience then singling out
and stringing together like beads on a
wire key noises that tell the story the
background is that Eric Bana and his
team are going to assassinate this man
in his home by getting him to answer a
phone that they've secretly had
installed a bomb in the string of
isolated plot sounds goes like this the
car with the assassins arrives the
dialogue of the targets wife and
especially young daughter then their car
pulling away signaling it's safe to move
forward then the coins and rotary phone
that will make the call then the priming
of the detonator and then
wait what was that
the first moment of trouble comes in
sound up until now the isolated noises
represent the steps of the plan going
smoothly the truck passing by represents
a break in that chain and a hitch in the
plan at this point the ambience outside
starts to take on some strange qualities
there's a high-pitched whine like a
train stopping on top of everything and
just like the moving truck blocks the
assassins view the movers talking keeps
them from hearing the daughter's car
pull back up to the apartment she plays
a key part in the scene so Burt isolates
her again but not her voice this time
her footsteps which continue indoors in
the apartment the ambience is quiet and
the really incredible thing about the
scene is that Burt and Spielberg build
the tension not by working towards a
great crescendo of noise but by
gradually subtracting elements once the
daughter is up here the danger can be
signaled by a single sound effect the
important elements have been set up so
well by this point you could follow the
rest of the scene without seeing it at
all oh my
I know allo the climax of this scene
brilliantly is silence but it's a
silence that works so well because it
anticipates the noise of an explosion to
come at this point the ambience has
become really impressionistic and when
it comes back in it has echo and reverb
it's hurried footsteps in an anxious
siren the whole sound universe
corresponds in a personal way to the
assassins to their feelings and their
nerves so it makes sense that when the
final question is asked it's the sound
design that answers Oh a on/off I'm not
sure what they're doing in film school
these days but if you have any interest
in making movies at all you should
attempt to make a scene like this no
dialogue no music just camerawork and
sound design
once you've finished it watch the scene
back but close your eyes wait and ask
yourself what are your ears see
[Music]
hey everybody thank you so much for
watching and welcome to the first video
of 2018 that is really exciting
just finished my little recharge break
over the new year which was wonderful
and I'm ready for the marathon that will
be this year as always I want every nerd
writer video on 2018 to be an event for
you guys I want it to be something that
really really stands out in your
subscription box and I'm gonna work very
hard to make that happen for you guys oh
I almost forgot
new nerdwriter mugs super exciting the
mugs are back check them out at the
dftba store you can find the link below
in the description you can see them
right here they're super cool so one of
those of you guys want yeah drink some
coffee out of a nerdwriter mug that's
cool this episode was brought to you by
Squarespace if you want to make a
website and you want to be a really easy
process Squarespace has some beautiful
award-winning designer templates to
choose from that just makes that process
of making a website so simple it's got
24-hour customer service no upgrades
nothing to install no patches ever and
picking your domain name whatever you
want it to be is really easy you can
start your free trial at squarespace.com
and if you use the offer code nerdwriter
you can get 10% off your first purchase
thank you so much for watching the show
subscribing being with me in 2018 this
is gonna be a fun year see you next time